[Music]  so i owe everyone  an apology the episode of real lawyer  reacts that i  just released involved some reactions  that are not my first reactions  to the show in fairness i had to think  about it  for months to untangle all of the legal  issues but  i need to do better i need to be able to  react to these things in real time  you've come to expect it and for that  i'm  sorry that it took me so long all i can  ask is for your forgiveness  so please don't watch this episode of  real lawyer reacts to better call saul  chicanery  don't watch the hilarious observations  and me basically falling apart trying to  untangle all of the legal issues you  deserve better this  chicanery he's done worse you deserve  better so please  exercise some restraint and do not click  on the link  to watch this episode of real lawyer  reacts  to better call saul